one third of the food we produce at 1.3
billion tons ends up as waste or gets
lost is 2050 the magic number well what
it is is a number that's not so far away
in the next 40 years as our numbers
swell demand for food will rise by 70
percent food scarcity will become more
acute and the richer will get richer as
the poorer well chronic hunger is found
in areas where people are really
isolated from the economy where they
have no access to land no access to
markets where countries and states are
failing for these people short-term
solutions are unfortunately only in
terms of food aid but that's difficult
still to reach them over to parliament
where workshop looked at europe's role
in feeding the world into 2050 by
finding solutions through the ways we
produce and consume food by cutting
waste and better biodiversity
is
so the good ideas are the simple ones
mups use the occasion to pass a
resolution to recycle food nearing its
cell by date and give that then to
people on the breadline a new diet was
also offered we should not be afraid of
modern technology what we need to look
at is very much in detail what can help
us to improve the food safety in the
food chain what can help us to do new
things for example use new species like
algae or insects for our mep it was a
case of eat more bread and pasta
what measures we take whether it's
promoting recycling of crops reducing
our land use emissions what we do will
impact our future